first off I'm wondering do you guys have
a the hunt Bible kind of like a we get
one little scene where they explain how
they put the whole thing together but
where you get into all of like the
nitty-gritty details of how the whole
Manor gate operation actually happened I
think that it's interesting you know we
over the course of making the movie
there was like some sketch of kind of
like what had happened and that in
shooting the movie we would constantly
add to and assume like more of things
like this must have happened this
character must have been involved in
this way and yeah but I mean that you do
see a scene a flashback to part of the
planning process on and that scene
truthfully honestly started as a joke
between the filmmakers about like what
they may have done but then we decided
like maybe it we should just we should
just do ad that show this like there's
also wondering about some of the I
always I'm curious about character names
but here it has even more meaning so
what were some of the most interesting
character names to come up with for you
I mean Krystal it just felt like I don't
know there was something about it
there's something about that name that
you have may have you have a certain
expectation about what the person's
gonna be and I just always constantly
flipping that with that whole character
felt right and I just I don't know that
that one was it was mostly instinctual
and then you know I don't know what I
feel like I you know yes II know it's
just I don't know it's Athena she's an
Athena non names like you know Staten
Island
what is it yoga pants Kid Rock well
actually you know in the in the original
screenplay
a lot of characters were names kind of
based on like clothing that they were
wearing just by virtue of kind of the
the story in that none of they were all
strangers didn't know each other
and so it was kind of described that way
and then I I think frustrated Nick a lot
I like changing what everyone was
wearing from what the the character
description was but it may I think we
all right turn down oh so much better I
mean it's like you know we we just had a
lot of fun with that like yeah it was
sort of like what what is a would is a
you know a quick sketch of that person
like what
but what is the archetype of someone you
know named yoga pants you ever thought
of what your archetype names would be
nerd black sweater black jeans for sure
that's what I would just be bangs the
tone of this movie is so so specific and
I imagine that was immensely challenging
to nail can you feel it working while
you're on set or does that come through
more so in the Edit process for you the
truth is like on set we would try one or
two things and we would be like it's
either gonna work that way or that way
you know and that third way we tried it
we know it's not gonna work and then so
then in the Edit room it became a bit of
you know trying our different options
but but it became really a thing of
onset you know doing an extra take not
just because the camera didn't work
right or or the sort of something wasn't
working but just doing experiments on
set was really a big portion of it you
know is there any example of a time
because you guys go really big with this
concept and I think appropriately so but
was there ever an instance where you're
like we're taken I don't know the gore
the humor or just something too far and
need to scale it back I think that we
would have conversations about them and
then we would just go to the there was a
yeah there was a version of it early
seen inviting a high-heel that was way
even crazily more graphic and gory than
what you see in the movie yeah so that
was just finding a balance of that
people didn't just you know wanna
there's to have their stomachs turned
but uh but no mostly it was like you
know I just remember like I didn't have
to have the burden of directing the
movie so I just like you know you gather
around a little a little playback
screens and Mychal people would just
gather round and watch the stuff and be
laughing hysterically so that's what I
knew that we were maybe in going in the
right direction